so we all know how this story goes by
now we've heard a version of it dozens
of times
the latest twist los angeles county
supervisor sheila cole
voted to ban outdoor dining in los
angeles county which would mean shutting
down
tens of thousands of businesses and
putting many of them under permanently
and then promptly right after this vote
went and dined outdoors at a restaurant
here's the fox 11 report from la it says
quote fox 11 received multiple tips that
shortly after her vote on tuesday cole
was seen dining outside at ilforno
trattoria in santa monica an italian
restaurant near her house that she has
previous
previously described as one of her
favorite restaurants when fox 11
investigative reporter bill mulligan
stopped by the restaurant to ask about
cole's visit managers told him
they quote didn't want to get involved
and they have no comment
now just a side note here i understand
that the managers
don't want to get involved um but they
should get involved
this ridiculous tyrant is trying to
destroy your business
she wants to take you down she wants to
impoverish your children
you should have banned her from the
restaurant when she showed up
you should have had security escort her
out out the door in front of everybody
you should have embarrassed and
humiliated her see
one of the aspects of this whole farce
of the lockdowns and everything
that else is going on is the
submissiveness of people
the people who should be standing up for
themselves churches not willing to fight
back against
insane infringements on their first
amendment freedoms business owners not
willing to
defy the orders from psychopaths like
sheila
um people obediently wearing masks even
just to walk outside down the street
because that's what they've been told to
do by people who don't wear the masks
themselves
the only way out of this the only way to
stop it the only end game
is for people to refuse to comply with
the dictates and commands
of petty tyrants like sheila just refuse
scoff at her waiver off continue doing
what you want to do
that's the only way as long as we
cooperate as long as we submit it's not
going to end
it will never end all right back to the
article it says during tuesday's la
county board of supervisors meeting cole
referred to outside dining as
a most dangerous situation
over what she described as a risk of
tables of unmasked patrons potentially
exposing their servers to the
chronovirus
she says this is a very serious health
emergency and we must take it seriously
the servers are not protected from us
and they're not protected from their
other tables that they're serving at
that particular time
plus all the hours in which they're
working cole went on to vote in support
of restricting outdoor dining in los
angeles county which passed by a three
to two margin
of the board of supervisors cole's visit
to the restaurant came before the
outdoor dining ban took effect wednesday
evening
but her decision is likely to draw
criticism from those who have grown
frustrated with elected officials taking
a hypocritical hypocritical approach
to what they have preached as cole dined
at the restaurant a mere hours
after she said doing such a thing would
be unsafe and would contribute to the
surge in coven 19 cases
now sheila did provide a statement to
fox via a spokesperson you could tell me
if you think this is sufficient
does this um is this enough to make you
say okay i'm satisfied she said
this is from the spokesperson says she
did dine at alfresco
uh did dine alfresco at ilforno on the
very last day it was permissible
she loves ilforno has been saddened to
see it like so many restaurants
suffer from a decline in revenue she ate
there taking appropriate precautions
and sadly will not dine there again
until our public health orders permit
oh she loves it you see she she loves it
but is in the process of demolishing it
she hates to see its decline in revenue
but she is personally and specifically
working
to take away its revenue you see how
that works
does that make sense to you no it
probably doesn't because you're not a
sociopath
in order for there to be this much of a
disconnect between what you say and what
you do
and in order to so casually decimate the
lives of so many millions for no reason
at all
and then to go and enjoy a nice meal
served to you by the very people whose
lives you are in the process of ruining
you must be a sociopath no mentally
healthy person could manage this
and there are a lot of sociopaths ruling
us right now as we have discovered so
a few points that i want to make here um
in no particular order
first is this i have a modest proposal
for politicians or
public health officials who violate
their own lockdowns or operate
in their personal lives in a manner
inconsistent with their public
fear-mongering
i propose that they'd be dragged into
the town square
tarred and feathered and then loaded
onto a helicopter and sent to gitmo for
30 years
now i'm not advocating vigilante justice
to be clear
i'm calling for actual legislation to be
introduced i want this all done legally
we could call it the
tar and feather hypocritical scumbags
act of 2021 or something
that might be a little too on the nose i
don't know we can brainstorm that part
of it
the main point is that people like
sheila should be treated with utter
contempt
and disregard and loathing that's what
she deserves
that's what she would receive in a
healthy republic
other than you know besides or
instead of politeness and submissiveness
you know a restaurant politely serving
her
after she just voted to destroy them
second point um it's worth reflecting on
another aspect of the problem
namely that the lockdowns and mask
mandates and all the rest of the covid
related initiatives
have empowered dozens hundreds of these
kinds of people all across the country
now we already know about the governors
like cuomo and whitmer who have gone mad
with the power they've been given or
rather have taken
and we know about the incompetent
floundering nitwit mayors like de blasio
and lightfoot
who've also enjoyed play acting as roman
emperors
but the real danger is that we have to
deal with lower level bureaucrats
especially old ones like sheila
who would have loved to have you know to
have gained real power and
maybe be mayors or senators or governors
or something on that level
but somehow lack the talent and charisma
of even bill de blasio
and so we're stuck for decades as county
supervisors
or town councilmen or whatever now even
those
people have the power to with the swipe
of a pen
lock people in their homes impoverish
them
plunge them into destitution and many
have taken full advantage
see a tyrant is not just a
dictator or like a warlord
a tyrant is someone who gets off
on exploiting whatever power they have
and whatever control they have
over other people there are parents who
are tyrants
there are assistant managers at home
depot who are tyrants hell there are
there are
customer service reps at the cable
company who are tyrants
they have a little bit of power and
control over you when you call the
company
and they're and they're manning the
phones and they answer and they're gonna
use it whatever little power they have
they're gonna use it to make your life
miserable because that makes them feel
better we've all we've all dealt with
people like this
they are tyrants just on the smallest
imaginable scale because that's as far
as they've been able
to go the problem now is that a lot of
low-scale
tyrants have been given way more power
than they were ever supposed to have
they've been given real power over your
life
and now we're all paying the price for
it third final point
and this has been explained many times
and shouldn't need to be explained at
all because i think it's rather obvious
but i will explain it because there are
still many people who are confused on
this point
when we talk about politicians or public
officials
not practicing what they preach when it
comes to coven
we're not playing a game of gotcha okay
that's not the point we're not going for
a ticky-tacky hair splitting sort of
thing here the point is that if they
really believe what they say they
wouldn't even be tempted to act
in a way that's inconsistent with what
they say if they really believed
that eating at a restaurant is a very
dangerous situation
they wouldn't want to do it themselves
you know so when you catch
whether gavin newsom was caught and he
said well you know
we all make mistakes yeah okay
that that excuse might work in in some
scenarios with politicians who do do one
thing and
you know say one thing do another when
they're making the kinds of mistakes
that
normal people would be tempted to make
but in this case
i mean you said it's dangerous it could
kill you why would you even be
tempted to do that if you really believe
it
the fact that they do things that they
have called dangerous and deadly
shows that they don't believe that those
things are dangerous and deadly
obviously
they are passing these laws and
ordinances and regulations
and decimating the economy and
destroying lives on a basis and using a
logic
that they do not believe
which means they aren't doing it for the
reasons they give because again they
don't believe those reasons
they're doing it for some other reason
and our point when we bring up the
hypocrisy is simply to ask
what's the real reason
sheila doesn't want to doesn't want to
shut down outdoor dining because she
thinks it's dangerous
she doesn't think it's dangerous clearly
so
why is she really shutting it down
that's our point that's our question
it's a good question
and the answer to the question seems
clear and has already been alluded to
she's doing it for power and control
that's why they're all doing
that's what all of this is about has
always been about
and it's time that the american public
finally wake up to that fact
hey you uh yeah you you're right you
right there hit the subscribe button
right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated